the entire vlog squad recently
collaborated with James Charles Brown
amazing thanks great what went down with
the sister squad I mean a lot we we I
don't know I'm allowed to say I don't
know we all reveal it some kind of a
relay race I don't want to say what it's
about but it was there's a lot of fun
James are super nice and I think we're
all a lot better at makeup after the
whole incident YouTube's changing its
prank video policy I hate it but I'm
yeah of course I mean it's probably for
the best but I'm not the biggest fan
because my videos a couple of my videos
were taken down because of it but
whatever yeah time where you can like
put up a different version of it or do
ever fight back yeah I kind of complain
about it and then my friends tell me
it's not worth complaining about and
then I kind of let it go there's not
really like a different version you can
use because you you made one version and
that's it yeah why don't you start your
own platform your own service award' I
would love to but it's not possible
because I can I can bring my audience to
a new platform but I can't bring like
newer audiences to a platform you know I
mean it's just YouTube some youtube's
impossible to feel it feels like love is
in the air for the blogs blood toddy and
Olivia Corinna and Logan have all these
new romances
giving you a lot of vlog material no
actually everyones so private now I
think like yeah they don't like talking
about it at all yeah I think because
everyone else everyone's relationship
was public at one point and it's in the
end too great so I think they're done
making things public um I just ask you
about the Trisha and Jason drama are
they gonna be able to make it through I
mean I they always figure something out
right well we'll see what happens thanks
for you like what video are we gonna see
that I have to pee that's the only thing
I'm worried about video wise I have no
idea I don't know I don't know what I
saw upload tonight I haven't even
started editing and you're gonna say are
you gonna like leave right after this
I'm gonna leave I came for this
interview then I'm out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]